this is a hiking trail
when you look at it or any other Trail
for that matter it can feel sort of
organic like nobody in particular
decided what it should look like but
behind almost every Trail are planners
Builders and designers crafting an
experience that gives people a tiny
taste of what real Wilderness feels like
and when they do their job right
it can feel like they were never there
[Music]
it begins with trying to understand the
visitors who will be using the trails
Jeff Marion studies the design of trails
and how they fit into the environment
people seem to really want to hike on
Native surface Trails you know in kind
of pristine
highly altered highly developed nature
with Pavements and things like that so
what makes a trail feel like pristine
nature for one thing there's its shape
unlike paved roads trails are often
built to mimic the imperfect natural
patterns of branches waterways or
lightning there's also the features a
trail connects with along the way
designers will often build a trail so it
touches anchors vertical features like
large rocks or trees that create a
pleasant frame on the edges of a trail
they also have to decide where it goes
so you sit down with your map and you
map out these control points designers
will identify the places people
shouldn't go like hazardous zones
private property and environmentally
sensitive areas and the places they
should like Scenic overlooks waterfalls
and lakes these are called negative and
positive control points and they give a
rough idea of where a trail can go
making sure a trail goes to the places
where hikers will want to go is
essential because if a trail doesn't
curious hikers will find their own way
to them creating desire lines that
Branch off from the actual Trail those
desire lines can disrupt Water Systems
plants or wildlife in ways the trail
designers didn't account for
and that's the Paradox of trail design
they're artificial Creations that need
to feel like they're part of nature but
also need to accommodate visitors all
without deteriorating over time
designers spend a lot of time thinking
about this but the force they're most
concerned about protecting trails from
actually isn't people
it's water
water is the natural enemy of a man-made
Trail it can erode a trail away make it
too many to use or change the shape of
it completely so we try to design trails
to be sort of invisible to that water
flow and that movement of water across
the landscape so hydrologically
invisible to do that they look at
topographic maps which illustrate a
landscape's elevation and they look at
the fall line that's the line that water
follows as it flows downhill if you
dumped a bucket of water on the ground
on a slope it would run straight down
the fall line if a trail runs parallel
to the fall line or too close to it it
becomes a pathway for water when it
rains the trail then sort of acts as a
drainage ditch going straight down the
hill over time that causes the trail to
erode and become wider but a trail that
runs perpendicular to the fall line
isn't good either because then water
can't flow down the hill at all if it's
dead level it's going to sit there and
make a big huge amount it's mostly just
you know poor design instead a good
trail runs diagonal to the fall line
cutting up a slope at an angle and
allowing water to flow across the trail
instead of down it and accounting for
the fall line is just one of the
principles designers look at to manage
water on Trails there's also grade
reversals where a trail alternates
between short uphill and downhill
sections this creates little valleys
where water can flow off of a trail in
smaller quantities there's the slope
which when it stays between a three and
ten percent grade is both comfortable
for hiking and minimizes erosion there's
the outslope a slight downhill tilt on
the trail that helps water flow downhill
and there's the tread the stuff the
trail is actually made of the higher the
proportion of rocks the better it can
resist erosion this careful combination
of alignment materials and shape can
help a trail last through years of
impact
even as those impacts become bigger than
they've ever been before we're getting
bigger rain events and they're having a
real toll on trails and so Trail
sustainability needs to focus way more
on tread drainage these days than we
ever used to
a lot of the work that trail designers
do isn't actually coming up with new
trails it's strengthening and updating
old ones many of which have been around
since before recreational hiking was
even something people did it's
challenging it's not rocket science but
it is challenging it requires kind of an
ecological knowledge of the inner
relationship of a wide number of
different factors out on a trail these
factors add up to an experience a
feeling of seeing a world that we didn't
make it's a world we don't often have a
way to see
and a good trail is our ticket in
[Music]